[Music]
foreign
[Music]
than any other powerful man who's
responsible for other people
if I had this part in the picture it
puts me right back up on top again
this Hollywood Big Show is gonna give
you what you want he says there's no
chance
I'm gonna make him an awfully camera for
you
know my father and then I come and get
to kill him now you want to get mixed up
in a family business
I thought you weren't going to become a
man like your father
[Music]
Freedom you're my older brother and I
love you but don't ever take sides with
anyone against the family again
ever
Michael do you renounce Satan and all
his works
don't ask me about my business is it
true
leave the gun
hey Nick cannoli
[Music]
thank you
the path of the righteous man is beset
on all sides by the inequities of the
selfish and the tyranny of evil men and
I will strike down upon thee with great
Vengeance and Furious anger those who
attempt to poison and destroy my brother
do you know what they call a quarter
pounder with cheese in Paris and what do
they call it Royale with cheese Royale
you got a corpse in a car minus the head
in the garage take me to it
baby
I love you pumpkin I love you honey
bunny everybody be cool this is a
rubbery
what's fun do you like cool correct the
Mundo and that's what we're going to be
we're gonna be cool
[Music]
I want to show you something this
rembrand here
it will come from all over the world to
see this yeah he's good yeah
to fake
apparently come back that's impossible
people believe what they want to believe
because the guy who made this was so
good
that it's real to everybody
notice the math stuff
the painter or the forager
[Music]
[Music]
no matter how I try to find my way
[Music]
[Music]
toast to a new era
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
I never took a quarter from a phone
booth you stole I just got bigger balls
than you
[Music]
London in the 1960s
everyone had a story about Grace
I come here for a proper shootout you do
with that rolling pit I'm gonna bake me
a cake which
you won't mind if I fly back with you
these are the cray twins Ronald and
Reginald
You Take My Breath Away you must be
Francis she figured we look alike
do you like being a gangster I like the
money and the respect
your brother wrong is Island and
psychopathic
we're talking about being gangsters
which is what we are the Murphy has made
inquirings London is going to be the Las
Vegas of Europe
we can handle it you come to
Philadelphia it's a nice Italian girl
we'll get it for you I prefer boys
Italians sometimes Greek but I am not
prejudiced you got a lot of balls
me and my brother we're gonna rule
London
they're not laughing now yeah
are you mad
do something about I can't do that
[Music]
he's my brother
she knows too many things about us we're
going down into the sewer after the
crates my loyalty for my brother is how
I measure myself what about your loyalty
for me crime is still a business you
don't want a wall
[Music]
yeah I do actually
listen to yourself one you're not blood
is thicker than water
[Music]
you won't Afraid of Anything learning
yourself you know
you
[Music]
we think he might be a Russian mafia
and he was a member of whatever in
Russian prisons your life story is
written on your body
and Tattoos I'm gonna have tattoos you
don't exist
[Music]
stillborn 20th December 23 14.
oh yeah where did you get this I found
it in the handbag the girl who died in
my ward I should bury her secrets with
her body
I'm a midwife I was hoping to speak to
the manager no no I'm so sorry if she
had worked here I would remember it is
said sorry I'll probably find out more
once I get her diary translated
a diary
you want to go for a drink it's
Christmas everything's closed sometimes
if things are closed you just open them
up this girl ended up in the hands of
the voice do you know what that means
they are always open doors he wants the
diary my son curios mentioned many times
I think he was threatening to harm the
baby if the Diaries would find its way
to the police okay boss you don't have
to worry police won't find anything she
was 14 she was just a child forget I
knew this ever happened stay away from
people like me have you read the diary
like you keep doing what you're doing
I decide what's right and what's wrong
you can't afford to be killed in any
area
I need to know who you are
sure so I respect this this respect
the more you were like a contagious
disease there's no cure once they've
touched you
I want you to play a game with me Ray I
don't want to play a game oh please no I
said play a game with me Raymond
right lovely
I want you to imagine a character your
boss Mickey piss you're too smart to be
blackmailing us Fletcher
sweet Mary Jane is my advice are you a
poison on the other hand is it always
has been the destroyer of worlds you're
out of touch and I would like you to
consider an offer
am not for sale
the plot begins to thicken
now I can't be specific about the heroes
and zeros but our protagonist is a
hungry animal
there is a lot of money hanging in the
Balance power antagonist explodes on a
seed like a millennial fireworks and has
indirectly started a war I think you
need to see this boss
[Music]
how do they find it
I'll make an inquiries
his name is
If You Smell Smoke it's because there's
a fire
do you have to stamp that out quickly
these people are going to clean house
and you are part of that house
in the jungle the only way a lion
survived
not by acting like a game
by being the king
brilliant
[Music]
oh it's really warming up now isn't it
[Music]
so you killed someone no it was the
gravity that killed him
oh do you need those phones
[Music]
the history of two generations of crime
the drama of absolute power and the men
who violate it The Godfather Part Two
what is your name
[Music]
Don Vito Corleone and his son Michael
both had seen the ones they loved most
cut down before their eyes
both had killed as an act of Vengeance
both commanded the most powerful and
merciless crime organization in the
world is it true that in the year 1950
you devised the murder of the heads of
the so-called five families in New York
complete fossil
they would take any measures You've Won
you want to wipe everybody out I don't
feel I have to wipe everybody out though
it's just my enemies
make any Arrangement Michael
bigger than us steel order any death
to protect the Empire they controlled
The Godfather and his Heir both were men
of ice and both were targets
[Music]
please please stay inside
The Godfather Part 2 is Sicily in 1921
[Music]
Nevada in 1958.
it is revolution in Havana
and rub out in New York
it is manipulation it would be like
trying to kill a president there's no
way we can get to it if anything in this
life is certain
if history has taught us anything
as soon as you can kill anyone it is
murder
and it is betrayal
it was a son a son and I had it killed
because this must
The Godfather Part Two is the final
chapter in the violent history of the
colione crime family
it is the motion picture Masterpiece of
the year
[Music]
I grew up in a tough neighborhood
sometimes reputation follows you Robert
De Niro is Al Capone there is violence
in Chicago of course but not by me not
by anybody I employ and I tell you why
because it's not good business
Kevin Costner is Elliot Ness I have
sworn to put this man away with any and
all legal means in my disposal and I
will do so
Sean Connery is Jimmy Malone you want to
get Capone here's how you get him he
pulls a knife you pull a gun he sends
one of yours to the hospital
you just joined the treasury Department
everybody knows where the booze is the
problem isn't finding it
the problem is who wants to cross the
pump
somebody messes with me I'm gonna mess
with him
you got a badge yes carry a gun
get your hands in the air you're all
under arrest you fellas are Untouchable
is that the thing no one can get to you
hey everybody can be gotten to all right
then drive to the station anything
happens
shoot first you understand me I'll tell
you one more thing
you've got an all-out price fight you
wait till the fight's over one guy's
left standing and that's how you know
who won just tell me are you being
careful careful is mice I want to hurt
some man alone I want to start taking a
battle to him I want a heart component
finger Al Capone this man could put
Capone behind bar
what's the matter can't you talk with a
gun in your mouth not to prove your
methods yeah
we're not from Chicago I want you to
find this Nancy boy Elliott I want him
dead I want his family
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Paramount Pictures presents a Brian De
Palma film I have for sworn myself I
have broken every law I swore to defend
I have become what I beheld and I am
content that I have done right you've
got nothing nothing and if you're a man
you would have done it now never stop
fighting for the fight is done
The Untouchables
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do you know what the difference is
between Adolf Hitler and Al Capone
it was dead Capone was like a king in
Florida
[Music]
he has full-blown Dimension I have a
reason to believe I could all be an
elaborate Act
what's this about we have information
that your client may have tucked away a
very large sum of money
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
page
we made a promise
someday we was gonna make it big
the only thing that really matters is
how magic it's his family
me are one was coming to me oh what was
coming to You Tommy
your world
enough
to my little friend
I'm so sorry Mr Corner no one ever
happened again I swear to God you're
talking to God so you might as well
swear to me
it's Mickey Cohen's Town you're not
going to change anything around here
Sarge
we're losing Los Angeles
I'm the future
I need you to wage war against Mickey
Cohen I'm looking to put a squad
together listening
small Squad
five maybe six guys
going up against 40. well you gotta die
of something
leave these at home nobody will ever
know what we've done we're not solving a
case here
going to war
[Music]
what's your racket handsome and my Bible
salesman
take me away from all this and make an
honest woman out of me no man I was just
hoping to take you to bed
you can't shoot me you're a cop not
anymore
[Music]
I'm looking out for you
[Music]
the cop is not for sales like a dog with
rabies
put them down don't go don't let me Los
Angeles is my destiny is that right
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I need to know everything you know about
the Winter Hill Gang and specifically
what you know about your former boss and
now fugitive James Whitey Bulger
oh what's that
in the beginning Jim was a small town
player it's a very small discipline
disciplined man take your shot but make
it your best cause I get up I eat you
know the next thing you know he's a damn
you know why because the FBI let it
happen I grew up with Jimmy and his
brother Billy the senator and that is a
bond that doesn't get broken my brother
he's waiting in this very dark Waters
Jimmy's business it's Jimmy's business
we all need friends
you and Jimmy
even you
I can help you Jimmy and you can help me
he's an alliance
I'll get the FBI to fight our boss
[Music]
[Music]
come around
how come no one is nailed Whitey Bulger
he seems to be involved in every crime
in the city and yet the bureau keeps
saying is clean what's polgen done
what's he done
everything
[Laughter]
if he gives me his word he will keep it
oh oh
oh
[Music]
we've sold the casinos we have no
interest in anything we were just
Church owns the large corporation worth
six billion dollars
this deal can make you one of the
richest men in the world
friends our business together is done
the road Partners they're unhappy
they think you abandoned them
just where I thought I was out they
pulled me back in
Mr colione we have a problem I said we
make them dead you give me the order and
take care of it
it's not personal Godfather it's only
business
you are the only one left in this family
with my father's strength
our true enemy has not yet shown his
face
[Music]
what is he White
oh boy
so what's the score
we're sending a man that works in an
office to pick something up you a part
of a babysitting team watching his
family while he does it good morning
everything is normal except
what do you want is that something you'd
say normal Monday I'm gonna shoot you
right now
can I go home now wait at the house
after what do you mean after but right
off of you
what is going on hold on big guy yeah
what are we doing we're following
instructions are you human helping you
are you not helping no no no no no no
set up man
God called me ten thousand dollars to
turn you in 15 white guy I think he's
the only one who can make a move I had
to make a move
I'd like to listen to the radio
it's been a long day
put this over here so I can relax
thank you
having a good time
we had a little slip up at work
I don't think that's the end of that
are you chickened out oh
gonna shoot
you're not smart enough to know how much
smart you are which makes you
unpredictable which makes you
untrustworthy
why are you doing this man cause imma
get what's mine
I'm sorry I'm gonna punch you now sir
I'm punching you this is going to be a
punch
the men that worked for me
must be capable of violence
why are we burning this place it's
called
trust you and trust you it's a valuable
commodity
it doesn't just work for you he's your
friend
[Music]
comes with this job it ain't
sorry to disturb you what are you
talking about and the distract
your boss has got another job for you
it's being taken care of
he made us I'm bringing him in
hey boss we have a possible
possible just get rid of the cop
s
no you're dead I'm tendering my
resignation
I'm gonna hunt you down what are we
going to do
you're a mob Soldier
well I've got guns
a lot of guns I'm taking that lady cop
back to Mr song
okay
just get rid of them both whatever the
cost you guys
learned one trip
criminals are Their Own Worst Enemy look
at me [ __ ]
thank you
[Music]
you have no idea do you
or did you choose not to know
your husband stole two million dollars
for me
[Music]
this is about my life
[Music]
this is about my life
and because it's about my life
and that becomes about yours
something happened tonight something bad
Mr Monica and your family's been
involved in Harry's life for many years
I need help I don't see what I can do
our husbands aren't coming back
and left me the plans for his next job
all I need is a crew to pull it off why
should we trust you anyway because I'm
the only one standing between you and a
bullet in your head
it's what I've learned from them like
your late husband and my father is that
you reap what you sow let's hope so
[Music]
this is for guns guns from where figure
it out
if this whole thing goes wrong I want my
kids to know that I didn't just sit
there and take it I did something
[Music]
[Music]
now the best thing we have going for is
being Who We Are
why
because no one thinks we have the balls
to pull this off
[Music]
[Music]
thank you